somebody asked why tonight why are they
opening the roof just maybe one of the
easiest questions that chris woodward
has gotten all season because it's not
smoking hot out it's a beautiful evening
and why not go ahead and enjoy this
beautiful evening in arlington luis
garcia will be the opener so expected to
throw just the one inning
and stella takes inside and it's a lead
off walk here's marcus
and that pitch is outside back-to-back
walks to open up the ball game for the
a's so here's laureano 3-2 pitch slider
and he walked in so garcia the opener
has walked the bases loaded olson 193
with 12 homers and 31 runs batted in and
here's the 3-2 delivery to matt and that
swung on and launched right field way
back and no doubt and right off the top
today matt olson hits a grand slam and
it's four nothing is with nobody out in
the first inning how do you like that
so with the grand slam four batters into
the game i don't know that you could
start a game any better than that for
the athletics taking on mike fires
making his ninth start of the season and
he'll do so with a nice 4-0 lead
tavares in scoring position got to take
advantage of that one the rangers want
to shift this momentum well solac with a
chance to drive in a run he has 19 rbis
this year
there goes tavares he's off and running
the throw to third not in time
eliot
with his fourth stolen base of the year
raiders i think it'd be huge just to get
even one run back this inning
and this one grounded up the middle they
will get one of those runs back it's a
4-3 put out two away but it's a 4-1 game
commander jordan lyles comes in the game
in the second inning these lead 4-1
murphy leads up the 1-0 pitch to murphy
is drilled to center field tavares going
back he will turn and watch it fly a
mammoth home run to center field by
murphy and the a's take a 5-1 lead swung
on gone
his fifth home run
everybody's pointing at where it went
yeah kai but i think they were pointing
to where they think it landed that baby
is still going and look at sean murphy
waiting to exhale
stay fair
somebody get that cameraman an l screen
all aboard so here's olson rangers play
the infield back it's 5-1 runners at
first and third one out in the second
there's a base hit right field
so la stella's gonna come in to score
marcus simeone trying for third he's
gonna make it as to throw his way off
line
so it's now six to one and that's a five
rbi game for olson and we're only in the
second inning i think markana
break out let's hit well to right field
gallow going back still going back
gallow couple steps onto the warning
track jumps up to make the catch simeon
will trot home to score it's a sacrifice
five for canada and it's seven to one
now stella bats with runners at first
and third
and there's another hit la stella slaps
one through the left side machine comes
in to score and it's eight to one the
a's lead they can do no wrong tonight
offensively so the lead-off man is
aboard and gotta bring leyote tavares to
the plate
from the stretch another quicker move to
first their good throw they pick them
off this time tajeda is picked off by
mike fires with a
fabulous tag by matt olsen now the 1-2
pitch with the bases empty he's a slow
curve a wave and a miss and tavara has
gone on strike so quickly two outs as
mike collects his second k is in command
after five with his leading eights and
one here's the pitch in grossman it's a
fly ball right field gallow back gallow
at the track right to the wall and he
leaps he can't get it it's gone and
grossman is homer to right nine to one
in favor of the a's
a high five ball that got
just over the leaping try of joey gallo
in right field
9-1-8 top of the sixth that's their
third home run tonight but robbie
grossman swing the bat very well for
these oakland a's just not enough from
the big fella elvis singled out into
right center as last time up
swinging the ball hit high into the air
deep right center field floriano going
back still going back and this one is
into the rangers bullpen
an opposite field home run for elvis
andrews it's his third of the season
and that makes it look a little bit
better up on the board rangers now
trailing nine to two elvis with his
third home run his seventh run batted in
in his fourth career home run off of
mike fire
three straight walks
after the home run to open the inning
tahita the switch hitter one for
two bouncer up the middle we'll go to
second one simeon onto first in time
for the double play they just get a run
out of it
now man at third with two gone leote
tavares 2-0
oh that one gets away coming in from
third guzman he scores standing up it's
9-4 inning opening walk to nick solac
two-gun and here is rugnetto door
oh dorp
hammers this ball out to right field and
that one is gone a two run homer
for odor is fourth of the year so the
rangers climbed within three
the last two at bats have been good ones
for rudinetto dora the walk and now here
we get the home run and a no doubter
here's la stella nice eyebrow
opportunity with the bases loaded and
one out
the two pitch is popped up
anders kind of left albus andrus into a
slide and he's got it coming in to
attempt to score his grossman and he
will score so grossman hustling home as
he helps la stella get an rbi and it's
ten to six sties trying to finish up a
win game one of this four-game series
joaquim soria comes in he is pitcher
number four so two outs here in the
bottom of the ninth
this should do it grossman
backs up a little bit moves over and
he's got it and that's the ball game so
the a's take
game one of the series and it's a big
series
[Music]